son tournoi de r Garos à lui ne pouvait
pas mieux débuter dès le premier jour le
plaisirou ramasse les balles du match de
Roger F il va transpirer pendant de
semaines sur les cours sans jamais
toucher une raquette apprendre à être
invisible au yeux des joueurs et le
comble dans tout ça il n'a même pas le
droit d'applaudir à la fin des points
pasette
chance est
centression que moi sa c'est déjà je
suis déjà content d'être
àaros Thomas n'avait pas été sélectionné
lors de sa première candidature habitué
des tribunes par le passé désormais au
bord du filet ce jeune joueur se rend
compte de l'importance des ramasseurs en
tant que spectateur normalement vient
toutes les années mais c'est vrai que je
faisais jamais trop attention au
ramasseurs on les voit pas trop c'est
vrai que c'est génial quand même d'être
sur le cours
et les joueurs ce jour-là le jeune
Plaisirois est affecté au cours numéro 6
avec un un premier match du tableau
féminin pour débuter avant chaque entrée
sur le terrain l'échauffement se fait
dans les allées au milieu même des
spectateurs son évaluateur note en
permanence la qualité de son ramassage
être sélectionné pour le tournoi du
grandchlem ne suffit pas il faut faire
partie des meilleurs pour officier sur
le cours central les critères c'est va
tout d'abord les rouler c'est une chose
importante c'est la transmission entre
deux ramasseurs donc on demande à rouler
plat rapide ça demande de la vitesse
aussi de la coordination et aussi euh de
l'anticipation et de la concentration au
maximum sur le terrain il a fait une
rotation très correcte avec son autre
paire de filet donc après on verra au
fur au fur et à mesure de la journée
parce que ils sont trois paires de filet
donc du coup ça tourne un petit peu
moins que les fonds mais après c'est à
lui de de se donner un fond pour pouvoir
passer sur le cours de transition demain
quoi le jeune yvelinois passe environ
3h30 par jour sur le terrain pendant
tout le tournoi il est dispensé d'école
mais n'oublie pas ses devoirs pour
autant car il reste les pieds sur terre
et sait qu'il ne pourra pas devenir
joueur professionnel il rêve désormais
de partager le cours avec Raphaël Nadal
peut-être lors de la finale le 9 juin
prochain